ننوه بالاخبار العاجله من جديد نقلا عن
مسؤول الناروسي الذي افاد بان اوكرانيا
قصفت المقر العام للاسطول الروسي في القرم
حاكم كان يقول بان الهجوم استهدف مقر
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود وان
القوات الاوكرانيه هي من شنت هذا الهجوم
على اثر ذلك السلطات القرن المواليه
بالطبع لروسيا حضرت حركه المرور على جسر
القرن مؤقتا سنتابع ايضا التفاصيل وما
تورده
الوكالات وكذلك
الجهات الرسميه في الاطار ينضم الينا الان
من موس ومراسله سامر يوسف اذا الاعلان
الروسي والمسؤول الروسي الذي يصرح قبل
قليل بالهجوم هل من تفاصيل حول طبيعه
الهجوم الاوكراني على الاصول الروسي في
القرم
ما قاله فقط الحاكم الروسي في سباستوبل في
القرن قبل قليل بان سقوط شظايا في وسط
المدينه بعد استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه
لاسطول البحر الاسود الصور التي شاهدناها
من هناك صور ما زالت غير واضحه حتى هذه
اللحظه يبدو بانها مصوره عبر الهاتف ومن
مكان بعيد ولكن هناك سحب دخان تبدو واضحه
في الصور لم يصدر حتى هذه اللحظه اي
معلومات اضافيه من السلطات الروسيه هناك
او من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي تحدثت
قبل يومين عن صد هجوم بتسعه عشر مسيره
اوكرانيه استهدف مناطق في شبه جزيره القرم
في الجنوب والجنوب الشرقي ايضا اليوم قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانها صدت هجوم
بمسيارتين على
جنوب الشرقي من شبه جزيره القرم يبدو بان
هذه الهجمات مستمره على شبه جزيره القرم
وتستهدف الاسطول البحري الروسي هناك
المنطقه ما زالت ساخنه حتى هذه اللحظه منذ
شهور تستهدف القوات الاوكرانيه او تحاول
استهداف
مقر السلطات الروسيه القوات الروسيه في
شبه جزيره القرم ولكن دائما ما كانت تعلن
خصوصا في الايام الاخيره المقبله وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بانها تصد هذه الهجمات
يبدو بان الهجوم الذي وقع صباح اليوم من
المرجح لم يصدر تاكيد حتى هذه اللحظه متى
وقع هذا الهجوم بالضبط ولكن يبدو بان هذا
الهجوم نجح بالوصول الى احد اهدافه على
الرغم من صيد العديد من الهجمات بصواريخ
وبطائرات مسيره استهدفت شبه جزيره القرم
ماذا يعني هذا هذا يعني بان هناك رد ربما
مرتقب من القوات الروسيه على
اهداف اوكرانيه كما يحصل منذ اكتوبر
الماضي عندما فجرت تفجر جسر شبه جزيره
القرم وبالتالي بعد يومين من حادثه
التفجير بدات القوات الروسيه حمله
الاستهداف اكبر للبناء التحتيه الاوكرانيه
في الداخل الاوكراني يوم امس وحتى اول امس
شهدنا قصف لمناطق حيويه في كيا في مناطق
اخرى داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وليس فقط على خط التماس بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه ان كان في دونتس او
في
خاركيف وقريات اخرى من هاكلي شيفكا لا
الامر يبدو بانه تطور اكثر
وحتى هذه اللحظه محمد كما اسلفت لا توجد
معلومات
كافيه ووافيه بخصوص استهداف اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي هناك في شبه جزيره القرن
التصريحات الاخيره تتحدث عن سقوط الشظايا
وسط المدينه بعد
استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا التصريحات
لحاكم سيف ستوبل الاستهداف كان لهذا
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود سقطت
الشظايا وسط المدينه طبعا نحن نتحدث
مشاهدينا حول هذا الاسطول الذي يضم عده
غواصات وسفن من المفترض انها ترسو في عده
موانع عبر البحر الاسود وكذلك بحر ازوف
وهذا الاصول يشمل مجموعه من الغواصات
والطائرات وحدات خفر السواحل ايضا قاذفات
صواريخ هذا ما اعلن انه
استهدف في اللحظات الاخيره وجسر القرم
الذي يحذر الان الحركه عليه كان قد تعرض
سابقا ايضا لتفجير شهير على العموم تاتي
هذه العمليه او هذا الاستهداف حسب
التصريحات الروسيه حتى اللحظه وسط الحديث
والازمه المتعلقه بهذه المنطقه واتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب المعلقه قبل قليل كانت
التصريحات حول مغادره باخره محمله بسبعه
عشر الف وستمائه طن من القمح
والغذاء متجهه الى مصر تتحدث اوكرانيا عن
خطوط بديله او ميناء بديل او ممر ابلغت به
الاطراف الدوليه من اجل استئناف طبعا
التصدير بعد انهار الاتفاق بين موسكو وكيف
لتصدير الحبوب كل هذه التفجيرات وهذه
الاحداث ربما الحدث الاخير يعقد من هذه
المساله على العموم تحدثنا عن هذا
الاسطول الروسي
المتمركز في صفه اسطبل اعود اليك سامر
وانت في المتابعه نعم تفضل انا في
الاستماع سامر
السلطات الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم محمد
تتحدث عن ان
الهجوم الصاروخي تم بواسطه صاروخ ستورم
شادو البريطاني واضاف المسؤولون الروس
هناك بان
شظايا سقطت بالقرب من مسرح وبان فرق
الطوارئ والفرق المعنيه تتجه الان الى
مركز الحادث حاكم
الروسي ايضا حذر من احتماليه هجوم اخر على
المدينه على الاسطول البحري ايضا ربما
لذلك دعا المواطنين هناك الى عدم السفر
الى مناطق الحادث والى عدم التحرك الا
للحالات
الطارئه ترد الاخبار تباعا وهذا اخر ما
تحدثت به السلطات الروسيه هناك